they've waited almost six years the
families of those who died that night
who came to hear and answer perhaps to
the biggest question of all whether it
could have been prevented
and they heard that there were
significant missed opportunities for the
security services and police to take
action that might have prevented the
attack intelligence about Salman abadi
that wasn't shared or acted upon actions
that might have stopped him killing 22
people and injuring hundreds more
oh my God
I have found a significant missed
opportunity to take action that might
have prevented the attack
it is not possible to reach any
conclusion on the balance of
probabilities or to any other evidential
standard as to whether the attack would
have been prevented
however
there was a realistic possibility that
actionable intelligence could have been
obtained which might have led to action
preventing the attack
a baby had been on the radar of the
security services for seven years they
knew about his contacts with known
terrorists even internet searches for
bomb-making chemicals but crucial pieces
of intelligence weren't put together
what could have even possibly LED police
to follow the car where he stored the
explosives he used that night for the
families of victims like Liam Curry and
Chloe Rutherford even now much of that
intelligence remains secret hidden for
reasons of National Security adding to
their frustrations at the security
services there's a lot of stuff that
could have been given to us even if it's
behind closed doors in the in the dawn
the general public to know but I think
we have a right we've had our children
murdered and I think we've got to got a
right to know certain things
for us it'll never end
because our kids are never coming home
and we've got two other children at home
our young adults at home and we don't
want this to happen again
do I believe it won't happen again
absolutely not it will happen again 100
sometimes the
the answers that they give you just
create more questions
um I feel really
um
I don't know it's like an end to
somebody but it's not an end for us so
like today is such a a big ending to
such a big inquiry but personally it
just it just feels no I feel numb
the inquiries findings prompted a rare
public statement from mi5's director
General
Gathering corvas intelligence is
difficult
but had we managed to seize the slim
chance we had
those impacted might not have
experienced such appalling loss and
Trauma
I am profoundly sorry
that MI5 did not prevent the attack
the family of the youngest victim
eight-year-old Safi rose russos that
apology does little when the
opportunities were missed for so long
and they still try and hide beyond the
truth and National Security the no I
don't accept apologies my eight year old
daughter is not something to be
apologizing for
do your job the evidence there
this was the final report from the
inquiry we already knew there were
opportunities to intercept a baby in the
moments before the attack and to save
lives after
now more failings revealed and no
comfort for those who lost so much Greg
Milam Sky News Manchester